Recently, while working on my Claude
code update video where I was covering
sub agents, Claude ultra mode and LSPs,
I briefly mentioned a new framework that
turns Claude into a fully autonomous
coding system. Shortly after, the
creator actually reached out to me to
thank me for sharing some light on the
project, which pushed me to do some
deeper dive into the project itself and
doubling down on my research. And after
spending some more time on it, I can
confidently say that this project is
truly remarkable. And this framework
that I'm talking about is called
AutoCloud. AutoCloud is an autonomous
multi- aent coding framework that can
plan, build, and validate software end
to end with minimal human intervention.
But what really sets it apart is that it
doesn't just work well. It looks
incredible. AutoCloud comes with a
sleek, modern, and intuitive UI, which
makes the entire autonomous development
process transparent and easy to follow
when Claud's actually working [music]
with multiple sub agents. Think of
AutoCloud as Claude Code, but on
steroids with additional agent
orchestration, [music]
planning layers, validation loops, and
powerful tooling that pushes it far
beyond a standard coding assistant. And
the best part is is that AutoCloud is
completely free and open-source.
AutoCloud has many features where it
obviously works autonomously and unlike
Ralph loop this is a framework that is
going to basically tackle your task
after describing the prompt. It is going
to handle every component of it but it
won't work at the same extent as Ralph
loop which works in a persistent loop to
get your task done regardless of how
many tokens it uses. In this case it
will autonomously handle the same steps
as it would with Ralph loop but it won't
go over and beyond. But regardless, you
still have many other features like
running multiple cloud code sessions
directly within the Cananban board,
which is a user interface that you can
access with AutoCloud. And it's awesome
because you can run multiple sessions
within this template. Now, you also have
other features like the isolated
workspace, self- validating QA, AI
powered mergers, memory layer, as well
as a GitHub and Git Live integration,
and a couple of other things. There's a
lot more to this, so let's dive straight
in. So, to get started, there's a couple
of prerequisites. You're going to need
to make sure that you have a Cloud
account, and you have two options. You
can use the pro plan, where you're going
to be able to use their subscriptions
tier directly within AutoCloud, or you
can simply just use a free Cloud account
and just link up your own billing
account where you just pay for the API.
This is the method that I'm going to be
using, but there are more efficient
methods with the Max Plan. if you are a
daily and active user of cloud code. But
regardless, just make sure you have
this. Next is making sure that you have
cloud code installed within your
terminal. And if you do not, it is super
simple. You can use the npm install
command which is listed within the
repository and you can install cloud
code. Then you just need to make sure
that you have git installed as well as
python 3.12 or above. Once the
prerequisites are installed, you can
easily get this started with two
options. You have the ability to install
it using the standalone app or you can
simply install this using the CLI and
this is with a CLI usage only without
any sort of UI. I'm personally going to
be using this with the application. So
I'm going to go ahead and actually
install the beta release which may have
more bugs but I want to have more
features a part of this. Before we get
started I just want to mention that you
should definitely go ahead and subscribe
to the World of AI newsletter. I'm
constantly posting different newsletters
on a weekly basis. So, this is where you
can easily get up-to-date knowledge
about what is happening in the AI space.
So, definitely go ahead and subscribe as
this is completely for free. After
installing, you're going to be greeted
with this main dashboard which will
welcome you to open up a new project or
you can simply open up a previous
project. I'm going to be starting off
with a new project and we're going to go
ahead and create a new folder. And this
is why you need git because you're going
to need to initialize your project. And
once you have it initialized, you can
either connect it with GitHub or GitLab.
And you can simply do so by having it
connected with the CLI. After
authenticating GitHub as well as your
own repository that you want to work
within, you have the ability to
customize a couple of things. Now, you
can tweak around with the memory, which
is where you can have that additional
memory layer when you're working within
AutoCloud, which I would highly
recommend that you do. And you can set
this up with Graphites's MCP server as
well. And this is something where you
can even use an embedding provider
locally with O Lama. So, if you have
that locally installed, you can do so,
or you can use Open AI, which I believe
is the best. Then after saving these
settings, you can then head back into
the linear settings and if you want to
integrate these different connections,
you can simply enable it. You can even
add in the cloud o if needed. And
there's general settings that you can
tweak like the agent configuration,
which model it is going to use. And one
great thing about autocloud is that
since cloud usually has a problem with
various sorts of limits, it is something
that can backfall to another model like
the sonet 4.5 directly within autocloud.
And it's intelligently going to do that
by having it set multiple agents with
different models so that once the limit
has been hit, it will transition to the
next model. And what I mean by that is
if you head over to the agent settings,
you have the ability to tweak the agent
profile. I'm going to keep it on
optimized with the auto mode. But you
can change this up for your own
preferences. You want a model to just
specify on planning, you can set that
with a specific model. And I believe the
creator of this project is going to be
integrating other models in the future,
which will be a gamecher cuz this will
be a great tool that can help you out in
so many ways. But now, this is
AutoCloud's main dashboard. This panel
is where you're going to be able to work
and have it complete multiple tasks for
you. Now, what we're going to do is
start off by adding in a new task, and
that is by clicking on this button. And
we can request it to accomplish this
task with the OP Opus 4.5. So, let's go
ahead and send in a prompt. This is
where I can be as descriptive as
possible and tell it that I want to
build a modern finance signaling app and
it will aggregate market signals to you
like the momentum, sentiment and
volatility with live APIs and AI
generated daily market briefs. Once you
have specified the description, you can
then select the agent profile that I had
mentioned and then the phase
configuration is where it will have it
so that it will use that spec driven
development system. So this essentially
has everything built within autocloud.
It will use the best frameworks to get
your generations outputed in the best
manner and with spec driven generations
like we all seen with openspec BMAD and
so many others it gets the best quality
outputed. So in this case it will use
the Opus 4.5 for creating all the specs.
It will code it out using the Opus 4.5
and you can obviously change this around
and customize it with other models like
the Sonic 4.5 or Haiku. I'm going to
leave it for Opus 4.5 as I believe this
would be the best. And now we're going
to go ahead and create the task itself.
You have get options as well you can
tweak but that is something that I can
leave for another day. Now within the
planning phase you'll see that it is
going to now start creating multiple
plans for sub agents to tackle. And you
can click on the start button which will
execute the planning process which you
can see is in progress. And currently it
is incomplete cuz I believe I need to
actually set my API key. Now this is
something that I had a problem with. But
if you are to provide a name and if you
are to authenticate any sort of cloud
account, it is going to request you to
either subscribe to a max account or a
pro account with claude. And if you do
not have that and if you want to use
your own API, what you can do is click
on this dropdown and you can paste your
manual API key from claude that's linked
to a billing account so that you can use
the Opus 4.5 within AutoCloud or this on
it. And afterwards, you'll see that it's
authenticated. Another thing, make sure
you set it as active. Then click save
settings. And what's nice is that you
have the ability to also access Cloud
Code within the agent terminals. And you
can get a live preview of all of the
agents working over here. You can
actually run 12 cloud code agents
simultaneously, which is incredible cuz
you can just simply add in multiple
terminals that you can run
asynchronously. But going back into the
canban board, you're going to be able to
see the progress and within the current
steps, it is going to work on planning
each and every step as to how it's going
to build out your specd driven workflow
for the agents to handle. But right now,
it is using multiple tools to get
everything ready for this. And then at
the end, it is going to condense and
create that plan. And then it will also
showcase the code and the validation
steps once it finishes this. And what it
can also do is it can create multiple
agents, multiple sub agents of cloud
code that you can then deploy and have
it tackle autonomously without you even
doing anything. You can also set it so
that you have human review so that you
can visualize each and every change that
it's making. What's also nice is that
autocloud will be able to use your MCPS
like context 7 in this case to get you
the most relevant uh libraries for this
particular use case of building the
modern finance dashboard. You also have
the ability to use ideation to generate
ideas about code improvements, UI or UX
security and it will actually list out
all of these things in the bottom
section over here once it finishes
generating it. So it looks like it has
finished generating ideas as well as
validating if there is any security risk
and you can see that there's actually a
critical one. So it will list out all of
the ideas and in this case if it's code
related you can categorize it UX or UI
docs security and performance and you
can actually click on one where it says
that my API is actually exposed and in
this case what I can do is I can convert
to auto to actually tackle that task. So
I can tell it to autob build this task
for me and it is going to then deploy it
to the cananban board and then I can
simply click on start and have it
execute that task for me. You can also
ask questions about your codebase so
that you can get a better understanding
of it as well. What's also cool is that
you can generate a road map as well,
which is incredible. And the road map
that it creates is pretty interesting
because it is something that has a lot
of phases that you can tackle the
features and the priority of what it
should focus on. But just take a look at
what it had created. And I got to say
this is probably one of the best
generations I saw Opus output of a
financial dashboard. Not only did it
create the dashboard, but it created a
fullon exchange where I can actually
trade as well as execute different
orders. And you can see there's a live
preview of the price with the order book
as well. You have the ability to
generate different sorts of AI
intelligence off of that stock or that
uh cryptocurrency. So in this case, you
can see that it provides me an AI
analysis on Nvidia. This is fake
analysis. Don't take this uh literally
cuz this is not the price of Nvidia. But
you can see that it tells you that uh
the momentum right now is deeding. So
you can go ahead and sell this right
now. But you also have a dashboard that
it generated where you can get a deep
analysis on each individual uh stock or
asset. And this is where it'll give you
a good idea of the momentum, sentiment,
and volatility. So overall, it did a
great job with the UI and the
functionality of this overall platform.
So I'm really happy to see that
AutoCloud did this autonomously. If you
like this video and would love to
support the channel, you can consider
donating to my channel through the super
thanks option below. Or you can consider
joining our private Discord where you
can access multiple subscriptions to
different AI tools for free on a monthly
basis, plus daily AI news and exclusive
content, plus a lot more. But that's
basically it guys for today's video on
AutoCloud. This is a remarkable
autonomous multi- aent coding agent that
uses cloud code and extends its
capabilities even further. And the fact
that we get this beautiful interface
that lets us visualize and deploy
multiple sub agents is incredible
because not only can you visualize these
agents working on your task
autonomously, but you have other
features like the ability to ideiation,
you have the ability to chat to the
agents and so much more like creating
road maps. But that is basically it
guys. I'll leave all these links in the
description below so that you can easily
get started. Make sure you go ahead and
subscribe to the second channel if you
haven't already. Join the newsletter.
Join the Discord, follow me on Twitter,
and lastly, make sure you guys
subscribe, turn on notification bell,
like this video, and please take a look
at our previous videos because there is
a lot of content that you'll truly
benefit from. But with that thought,
guys, have an amazing day, spread
positivity, and I'll see you guys fairly
shortly. He suffers.